turmoil at Clark County School District  spills out of the boardroom and well  into the street last night protesters  gathered outside the home of board  president Linda Cavazos she says they  yelled about mask mandates and claimed  the coronavirus was fake about three  dozen protesters as you see were seen  outside her home  they were yelling about mask mandates  and about the covid virus being fake and  that we were suffocating their children  with Mass  the protesters left after a few hours  Cavazos says some of them said quote  Katie sent us pop sauce possibly rather  referencing CCSD board member Katie  Williams in a tweet Williams says she  does not support this kind of protesting  outside of a personal residence for any  public figure